[Musique]
là monsieur bonsoir conseil des
ministres exceptionnel aujourd'hui à
l'elysée le porte parole du gouvernement
vient à l'instant d'en révéler la teneur
le gouvernement a arrêté une série de
mesures d'urgence destinées à enrayer
l'agravation des déficits des dépenses
publiques à commencer par la sécurité
sociale
voici une première liste de ces mesures
dont max gallo vient donc d'annoncer la
nature le nombre des médicaments
remboursés sera considérablement réduit
la liste on sera publié dans les jours
qui viennent
le montant du forfait hospitalier à la
charge des malades est augmenté de 300%
les allocations familiales seront
supprimés pour tous les foyers dont les
ressources dépassent 8000 francs par
mois
les retraites seront versées par la
sécurité sociale
leur montant sera réduit de 20 à 70 %
selon les catégories
l'indemnisation des chômeurs sera
diminué de 20%
d'autres mesures seront annoncées demain
on n'en sait pas plus pour l'instant
mais déjà ces décisions du gouvernement
apparaissent évidemment comme un
événement politique et économique
majeure rien n'avait filtré de leur
préparation
même si l'aggravation de la conjoncture
en explique l'urgence les réactions
syndicales et politiques promettent
d'être virulentes
le point complet sur ses réactions et
sur les mesures elle-même dans notre
dernier journal à 23 heures
rassurez vous rassurez vous cela n'est
pas vrai ce flash est un fossé nouvelles
sont imaginaires mais avouez que vous
avez eu peur parce que dans le fond ces
mesures elle sonne vrai elles donnent
une idée de ce qui nous attend si la
crise s'aggrave tous les jours comme moi
vous entendez parler de catastrophe
économique d'inflation de chômage etc
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qui s'est déréglé dans le monde
certains disent que c'est un cafouillage
passagers de l'économie d'autres qu'il
s'agit d'une
catastrophe dur à d'autres enfin que
c'est le début d'une véritable mutation
qu'un nom de nouveaux commencent mais
tout ça c'est abstrait puis moi je suis
comme vous j'aimerais bien y voir clair
comme vous je me sens embarquer malgré
moi dans une énorme affaire qui
m'échappe
alors que vous l'avez sans doute fait
j'essaie de comprendre et de me faire
expliquer tout ça clairement en fin de
compte je me suis aperçu que leur
fameuse crise quand on archontes
l'histoire toute l'histoire
cela peut devenir aussi passionnant
qu'un film vous allez voir
[Musique]
demain
oh
non
[Musique]
la crise quelle crise tout le monde en
parle autour de nous comme d'un désastre
avoue pourtant que ce désastre lane
n'est pas spectaculaire
je veux dire comparer avec ce qui se
passe ailleurs dans le monde
chez nous les choses n'ont pas l'air
catastrophique pour la plupart des gens
la crise ce n'est encore qu'un mot mais
oui parce que nous mangeons à notre faim
et nous sommes en paix le pays profite
malgré certaines inégalités de privilège
incroyable
le problème c'est que ces privilèges
nous y sommes tellement habitués que
nous ne remarquons plus et pourtant ces
privilèges il suffirait de les
redécouvrir avec un regard extérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma soeur panne ya cinq jours déjà que
nous sommes à paris
dès que nous sommes arrivés nicolas
s'est mis au travail avec sa délégation
pour persuader les français d'acheter
les produits de nos ambitions
moi ce trou de sectionner des bizarre de
vouloir le revendre quelque chose parce
qu'ici on dirait qu'ils ont tous
pourtant en deux jours nous tous les
jours il parle de la crise se doit
exister puisque il lui dit n'empêche des
crises comme ça on en voudrait bien chez
nous
le perçoit on a dîné chez des amis
français
lee il est ingénieur dans une entreprise
et l institutrice avec deux enfants il
dit à 4 ans une appartement de 50 m²
je ne te raconterai pas notre repas mais
tanya j'en suis sûr maintenant livrer
crise qui les menacent ce français celui
crise de foie boudou
je fais les vitrines bien sûr la
première chose qui surprend ici ce qu'il
n'y a pas de queue devant le magasin
d'ailleurs ici ce ne sont pas les
clients qui se discutent les médecins
disent ce sont le tholy marchand qui
dépensent plus d'argent avec leurs
publicités pour que tu te décides entre
deux douzaines de modèles de voitures ou
d'appareils ménagers
j'ai vu des choses étonnantes dans sa
boutique de brosses à dents avec un
petit moteur dedans de l'aspirine qui
fait des bills et même des machines
électroniques pour prévoir l'avenir
je me dire à toutes ces choses ne
servent à rien et byatt et newscan ici
c'est comme si elle était indispensable
et peut-être bien plus tous qu'ils ont
raison finalement ce serait l'histoire
qu'elle raconte ce new look sida écrit
la cause mais qu'est ce qu'il sent bon
en effet pour quelqu'un qui vient
d'ailleurs de sibérie ou du tiers monde
par exemple notre crise ne se voit pas
et pourtant dix ans et oui cela fait dix
ans que dure cette crise elle a commencé
en 1973 avec ce qu'on a appelé le
premier choc pétrolier et dix ans après
l'europe n'a pas l'air de souffrir très
gravement
pendant ces dix ans de crise au
contraire et c'est ce qui est paradoxal
nous avons continué à consommer toujours
davantage curieux non
comment cela est-il possible et bien
parce que nous avions des réserves
d'énormes réserves de richesses ses
réserves étonnante elle ne sortait pas
du néant elle était le produit de 30
annexe ordinaire de 1946 à 1976 des
années qu'on appelait à juste titre les
trente glorieuses et pendant ses 30 ans
et sans toujours nous en apercevoir
nous sommes prodigieusement enrichi cela
ne s'était jamais vu dans l'histoire
n'ont jamais dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité
telle est aujourd'hui le saviez vous
nous gagnons en moyenne trois à quatre
fois plus que le parent donc je veux
dire un pouvoir d'achat
cela vous paraît incroyable moi aussi
et pourtant
quatre fois plus riche qu'est ce que
cela veut dire concrètement
comme vous je serais bien en peine de
m'expliquer en détail je sais pourtant
qu'il suffit de regarder autour de soi
pour le contrôle et madame lambert qui
appartient à la classe moyenne française
comment était son appartement dans les
années 50 et comment at il changé en
trente ans et bien c'est aussi cela
vivre un pays qui s'enrichit
souvenez-vous domine ou le printemps
chantant mois dominique le sol et s'est
fait le mercredi dès lors comme à quelle
journée
alors y avait le lâche blanc le lâche de
couleurs et puis cette cce ce que je
devais surveiller parce que ça ça dépend
des zooms encore à ça le buffet en
importance car on stockait rappelez vous
c'était la fin de la guerre alors on a
donc quand la queue devant les magasins
le charmant et oui le charbon à la carte
qu'il fallait monter quatre étarras
105-116 tous les jours
j'écoutais lattes et c'est sûrement il
se peut qu'à mon tour je te fasse
là
[Musique]
on n'a pas été les premiers à voir une
poste de télévision je me souviens il
fait attendre dix minutes avant que la
l'image apparaisent keller le
chauffe-eau l'évier la machine à laver
que de temps de gagné
ouais
bourg madame lambert comme pour chacun
de vous la crise aujourd'hui est donc
disons comparativement supportable la
dernière fois qu'on avait parlé de crise
en effet c'était tout autre chose
dans les années 30 la crise économique
cela se voyait
croyez moi
[Musique]
oui ce que les gens à qui la menait à
l'époque c'étaient des choses
essentielles manger survivre
la crise c'est l angoisse l'exode des
chômeurs sur les routes les raisins de
la colère dans les villes du monde
sportif se former j'étais le drame
aujourd'hui bien sûr il ya des
revendications importantes et 2 millions
de chômeurs
j'ai vraiment excité c'est vrai mais il
ya aussi certains problèmes qui font la
une des journaux et qui tout de même
n'ont rien à voir mais là vraiment rien
à voir avec les drames de 1929
le reste des privilégiés c'est vrai et
certaines de nos revendications de nos
pays pourrait faire sourire tout le
monde rit pas le 13e le 14e quelquefois
le dc cam main la sécurité de l'emploi
davantage de vacances moins de soucis et
s'étaient quittés activités parfois on a
raison mais second étage et nous salue
bien on peut estimer en cinq ans notre
baisse de revenus ne revive c'est son
chiffre d'affaires il faut reparler et
l'ordre de 40% mais ça se concrétise
comme ça comment dans votre vie courante
à bas par un certain nombre de services
que nous pouvions que nous supprimons
l'employée de maison
c'est simple je crois qu'il doit y avoir
une trentaine de 1058 le français qui
ont fait que moi qui a abandonné
employés ont supprimé l'an après mûre
les revendications immédiates
c'est le pouvoir d'achat on accuse déjà
5 % de perte de pouvoir d'achat pour
l'année 83
ce fils arsène la réduction
du temps de travail à 35 heures sans
diminution de salaire aux avantages en
nature visite année là aussi on ne tient
plus que jamais c'est un élément de
notre rémunération
combien peut prier kg 4 centimes au lieu
de 45 centimes pour un usage
domestique donc ça fait partie de nos
salaires on doit pas y toucher mon
problème le problème de tous les
personnels c'est que nous sommes
contraints et forcés de quitter les
locaux de la maison de la radio que nous
occupions depuis juillet 76 pour
emménager sur décision gouvernementale
dans une tour situé dans le 15e
arrondissement
or ces tours et à air conditionné et
d'autre part il n'y a aucune possibilité
d'aération l extérieur c'est à dire que
les fenêtres sont totalement fermés 1929
et 1984 regardez bien quand on compare
ces deux dates et ces deux images on
pourrait dire en effet que la crise
d'aujourd'hui notre crise à nous n'est
pas bien grave apparemment tous nous
pousserait à nous consoler de cette
façon eh bien on aurait tort en
profondeur derrière le décor elle est
bien plus grave qu'on ne le croit cette
crise on n'en trouve pas encore beaucoup
c'est vrai mais c'est toujours comme ça
au début d'une maladie les symptômes
sont bien là et vous les connaissez très
bien chômage inflation faillite impôts
qui augmentent déficits commerciaux etc
etc
quant à la maladie on peut la résumer en
quelques mots un la croissance et
arrêter de nous avons cessé de nous
enrichir
et si jusqu'à présent grâce aux trente
glorieuses de la croissance on a pu
vivre cette crise à crédit est bien là
maintenant il faudra payer
cessons donc de rêver parce
qu'effectivement
c'est grave ou
[Musique]
oh
il a risqué leur vie pour l'exposition
coloniale internationale à laquelle la
france a convié les nations y est a
remercié les éminentes personnalités
dont le propos gaffe permis sous le haut
patronage de lait par ajouter un sens
précis
sigler un nouvel éclat vous voyez
monsieur le président
la fin en un quart d'heure nettement du
monde
jeudi mme adam du dvd dans les pays de
langue arabe al hayat que vous êtes à la
vue de ces planètes voisines la langue
rugby et la brûlante afrique et la tire
seulement ce tous faire baiser la
dialyse
lui et olivier encore nous étions des
nantis des histoires un peu les maîtres
du monde et depuis longtemps
c'est grâce à tout cela aussi que nous
nous étions enrichi nous avions comme on
dit et comme on l'expliqué des
privilèges historique
or c'est peut-être dur à admettre mais à
présent cela ait changé comme et changer
la carte du monde de fond en comble la
plupart de ces privilèges sont bel et
bien perdu c'est fini
fini l'énergie bon marché sous de gaulle
le pétrole coûtait dollars le baril et
le dollar à quatre ans sous giscard il
en coûtait 18 soumis tran c'est 30
dollars et de dollars à 8 francs 30
cela fait trente fois plus fine et les
matières premières pour presque rien
aujourd'hui les choses comme le cuivre
fer de nickel ont suivi le même chemin
du pétrole et l'europe n'a presque pas
de cuivre de nickel de faire finie la
jeunesse vous savez tous que la natalité
chez nous s'est effondré et que l'europe
devient un continent de vieux mais savez
vous aussi qu'au rythme démographique
actuelle la population d'un pays comme
l'allemagne de l'ouest par exemple aura
pratiquement disparu dans trois siècles
est enfin finie la puissance militaire
savez vous que de petits pays comme la
syrie israël ou le vietnam ont davantage
d'avions et de chars que la france
nous avions un autre privilège est
capital si la wii en effet nous étions
les seuls dans le monde va maîtriser la
technique à fabriquer certains objets et
bien aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
tenez regardez les objets qu'ils
achètent et madame lambert pour son
appartement
ils ont été fabriqués à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez elle
comment cela se fait-il pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont mieux fait moins cher plus
modernes et bien arrêté en réalité ce
qu'il montre c'est qu'un événement est
de taille a frappé l'europe
nous ne sommes plus les seuls maintenant
à savoir maîtriser la technique des
concurrents sérieux ont surgi à travers
le monde et surgissent sans cesse de
plus en plus il vaut mieux que nous et
plus vite et moins cher
l'europe aujourd'hui et peut-être en
voie de sous développement
voyez vous ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est michel albert ancien commissaire
au plan et spécialiste des questions
économiques européennes
[Musique]
l'europe existe-t-elle à bruxelles ce
jour là michel albert rencontré une fois
encore quelques dizaines d'experts
internationaux y at il une ou plusieurs
façons de sortir de la crise l'europe
est elle condamnée inexorablement à
glisser sur la pente du déclin est elle
en voie de sous-développement
[Musique]
sous-développement assez un mot fort
sous développement
ce qui est vrai c'est que la crise c'est
plus que la crise
c'est une espèce d'immense retournement
historique et que dans ce retournement
historique peut-être bien en effet que
l'europe commence à glisser vers le sous
développement et comment est-ce que ça
peut se traduire de façon concrète
écoutez regardez autour de vous regardez
en france regardez nos principales
industries celles qui sont les plus
beaux fleurons de nos activités
pensez aux textiles penser aux régions
sinistrées du textile les vosges par
exemple deuxièmement penser à la
sidérurgie
alors la crise sidérurgie région
sinistrée l'honneur la lorraine tout le
monde sait cela pensez troisièmement à
une activité qui a fait notre gloire
autrefois la france
quand j'étais gosse c'était le pays du
normandie c'était l'activité de la
construction navale pas penser à ce qui
se passe à saint nazaire à la ciotat à
la scène voyez bien là encore nous
sommes en pleine crise
et puis et puis quatrième exemple qui me
vient à l'esprit
même l'industrie automobile qui est
certainement celle par laquelle la
france a surpris le plus le monde depuis
une génération
vous voyez ce qui se passe penser à
talbot penser à poissy même là il faut
faire des licenciements aujourd'hui et
même si vous prenez les activités à
l'heure les plus avancées vous vous
rendez compte que c'est tout le problème
de la troisième révolution industrielle
et que l'heure est peut-être bien en
train de rater la troisième révolution
industrielle a je crois que il faut
qu'on s'arrête un instant pour que tout
le monde comprenne bien de quoi il
s'agit il ya eu depuis un peu plus d'un
siècle de grande révolution industrielle
qui ont incroyablement améliorer nos
conditions d'existence à nous les
européens c'est d'abord la révolution de
la machine à vapeur et des chemins de
fer c'est ensuite la révolution de
l'automobile et du moteur électrique
ces deux révolutions elle était en
europe elles sont nées en europe et la
troisième révolution industrielle celle
de l'informatique de l'électronique bah
c'est pas là que ça se passe
c'est dans des pays lointains c'est sur
les bords du pacifique en californie au
japon tout le monde le sait ce que vous
avez un ordinateur chez vous by gg mieux
que ça g et tenez un exemple voilà un
exemple la petite calculette qui ne me
quitte pas ça c'est le dernier modèle de
calcul est de machines à calculer qui
fonctionne sans pile inusable à la
lumière du jour c'est la dernière
production japonaise quand on dit que
l'europe et peut-être bien en voix type
de sous développement et que nous sommes
en train de rater la troisième
révolution industrielle c'est à des
choses comme ça qu'il faut penser parce
que nous par exemple les français nous
ne serons peut-être jamais capable de
produire d'une manière compétitive et
rentable un produit comme ça qui va se
joindre à des centaines de millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde
dans le cas où l'europe vraiment ne
serez pas capable de reprendre sa place
dans la troisième révolution
industrielle alors je peux poser la
question de savoir si un jour nous nous
risquerions pas à tous égards de devenir
une espèce d'afghanistan nous risquons
d'avoir un troisième choc pétrolier donc
à troisième choc énergétique
or est-ce que vous croyez que les pays
d'europe sont en train de s'unir pour
lutter contre ça pas du tout pas du tout
nous sommes en train au contraire de
nous chamailler les uns les autres
nous sommes en train en quelque sorte de
faire comme des vieilles dames qui pour
maintenir leur niveau de vie
eh ben mon dieu vendre leurs bijoux
comme ça hein hein alors c'est pour ça
que je comprends votre question c'est
qu'en effet quand on vend ses bijoux
on a encore l'impression d'être riche on
donne encore l'impression d'être riche
et en réalité on est vraiment en train
d'entrer dans un déclin qui risquent
d'être irrémédiables
et oui comme vous le voyez c'est grave
mais ce n'est pas tout une chose qu'on
marque moins mais qui peut-être plus
dangereuse que tout le reste c'est le
désordre monétaire international quand
on évoque ces choses là je suis comme
vous j'ai souvent du mal à m'y retrouver
j'avais tendance à me dire que les
affaires financières du monde et être
compliqué beaucoup trop compliqué à
comprendre
eh bien j'avais tort je sais maintenant
que si ces difficultés là demain
s'aggravait on se rendrait compte
finalement que les choses sont plus
faciles à comprendre qu'on imagine oui
plus facile plus facile mais plus
terrifiante aussi car imaginer qu'un
pays du tiers monde refuse de payer ses
dettes
eh bien regardez le mexique ne paiera
pas trois semaines après son retour au
pouvoir le président lopez portillo
déclare devant une foule estimée à plus
de 700 milles personnes que son pays à
annuler unilatéralement la dette de 80
milliards de dollars qu'il avait
contractée auprès des banques l'occident
diffusée dans tout le pays
le discours du président lopez portillo
provoque des explosions de liesse
nationaliste et rallier au gouvernement
toutes les forces politiques et
syndicales de la nation
il est 9h du matin au japon
quand le président lopez portillo
termine son discours c'est à la bourse
de tokyo que la décision mexicaine fait
sentir ses premiers effets les actions
des banques les plus engagés au mexique
commence à baisser le dollar s'effrite
et l'orgue 1 10 points en une séance
des stands ouest longue de choc se
répercute sur toutes les places
financières
à mesure que les bourses des valeurs
entre en activité à koweit la baisse
s'amplifie à londres et à paris
elle s'étend à toutes les valeurs
bancaires à new york une dizaine
d'heures plus tard c'est la chute
les banques les plus menacés sont les
banques américaines en fin d'après midi
la maison blanche est obligé de réagir
le président ronald reagan déclare que
son administration est prête à
intervenir en cas de besoin
mais dans l'immédiat le président estime
que le secteur privé est assez solide
pour faire face de lui même à la
situation
[Musique]
denis kessler que pensez vous de la
position que vient de prendre le
gouvernement américain la décision du
gouvernement américain est extrêmement
dangereuse extrêmement irresponsables
l'aboutissement du pensée néolibérale et
on je crains malheureusement que le
gouvernement américain n'est pas mesuré
toutes les conséquences économiques
sociales financières de la décision qui
vient de prendre et plus précisément
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
situation qu'ont les banques qui sont
directement engagée au mexique oui les
grandes banques américaines se sont
montrées particulièrement irresponsable
tout au long des années soixante dix
voire même au début des années 80 elles
ont prêté des sommes absolument colossal
au mexique mais aussi au brésil ou à
l'argentine ou à d'autres pays en
développement or ça a été un métier
extrêmement lucratif mieux que de prêter
à ces pays là mais elles se sont exposés
à des risques tout à fait inconsidérés
pour vous donner simplement quelques
chiffres la bank of america a prêté deux
mille cinq cents millions de dollars au
mexique simplement ceux ci représentent
60% des fonds propres la chase manhattan
qui est bien connu à prêter 700 millions
de dollars uniquement à ce pays là ceux
ci représentent 50% des fonds propres
bien entendu elles ont prêté également
comme je le signalais au brésil ou à
l'argentine qui sont également dans des
situations économiques extrêmement
troubles
en d'autres termes les banques
américaines sont en état de faillite
mardi matin devant l'attentisme de
l'administration américaine
des rumeurs de faillite commence à se
propager de nombreux déposant affluent
aux guichets des banques afin de retirer
leur argent à midi à la suite d'appels
pressants des dirigeants de la city cops
et de la chase manhattan bank
ronald reagan annonce que son
gouvernement garantit toutes les
créances mexicaine nous ne sommes pas en
1929 déclare le président mais le simple
rappel de la grande dépression des
années 30 provoque aussitôt un mouvement
de panique
profitant de la pause du déjeuner des
milliers d'américains se ruent dans les
agences bancaires pour vider leur compte
à 15 heures les banques doivent fermer
leurs portes faute de billets pour
satisfaire toutes les demandes
malgré les communiqués officiels les
rumeurs de faillite en chaîne s'amplifie
mercredi à 5h du matin ici d'attenté se
forment devant les guichets
sur tous les territoires des états unis
[Musique]
au mali en appel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ban
est ce que ces menaces concernent
également la france que les banques
françaises par exemple été beaucoup
engagé au mexique mais ça concerne tous
les pays occidentaux et la france
peut-être plus particulièrement que les
autres pays les banques françaises
également tout au long des années 70
sont prêté massivement aux pays en
développement et l'exposition au risque
des banques françaises notamment aux
risques mexicain mais aussi aux risques
brésiliens ou au risque d'autres pays en
développement est tout aussi important
que l'exposition au risque des banques
américaines ou anglaises
mercredi 10 heures du matin le système
bancaire américain se trouve defacto en
cessation de paiement très vite la
panique gagne aura partout la foule
tentent de pénétrer en force dans les
agences des grandes banques européennes
la police doit plusieurs fois intervenir
pour éviter l'émeute l'après midi du
même jour
les ministres des finances et les
gouverneurs des banques centrales des
pays industriels se réunissent à bâle à
paris
le gouvernement est violemment pris à
partie lors de la séance des questions
orales à l'assemblée le conseil des
ministres s'est réuni d'urgence
[Musique]
à 16 heures au cours d'une conférence de
presse gérard paillard président de
l'association des banques françaises
s'efforcent de rassurer les épargnants
il rappelle que le système bancaire
français est nationalisé par conséquent
l'état garantit formellement la sécurité
de tous les déplacements sur président
en dépit des assurances données par vous
et par le gouvernement les déposants
continue de se précipiter au guichet les
banques
est ce que vous êtes en mesure de
satisfaire toutes leurs demandes les
déposants non les déposants n'ont aucune
raison de s'inquiéter parce que nous
avons la situation parfaitement je vous
en présente plus précisément y at-il
dans leur coffre assez de billets pour
satisfaire à toutes les demandes
bien sûr nous avons passé tous les
accords nécessaires avec la banque de
france a déjà provisionné aux billes
tous les acteurs ont été dépassés toutes
les demandes seront satisfaites excusez
moi monsieur harper excusez moi
d'insister mais le total des dépôts à
vue en france représentent actuellement
700 milliards de francs la banque de
france peut produire au maximum un demi
milliard de francs en billets par jour
donc il vous faudrait quatre ans et demi
pour renverser pour nous fait vendre
c'est les chiffres du ministère qui sont
la cible initiale écouter s'il vous
plaît écoutez le gouvernement est réuni
depuis maintenant deux heures environ et
le sans préjuger de ses décisions
il ya une chose que je peux vous
garantir c'est que les intérêts des
épargnants seront préservés et que tout
sera fait mais vraiment tout pour que
dans les quelques jours qui viennent
afin d'en plus brefs délais la situation
ne devienne parfaitement normal
messieurs je vous remercie
dès le lendemain le gouvernement faisait
jouer l'article de la constitution qui
l'autorisent à légiférer en urgence en
une journée
le parlement a adopté le plan suivant
blocage de l'epargne sur dix ans
limitation sévère de l'usaj d'échec
blocage des prix blocage des salaires
sur 12 mois les restrictions de la
circulation monétaire provoque une
baisse de la production industrielle de
32% une baisse du pouvoir d'achat de 19
% une augmentation de 110 % du nombre
des faillites d'entreprises
six mois plus tard
la france compte 9 millions de chômeurs
quand on voit ce qu'on vient de voir
on se dit que cela va pas arriver que
c'est trop dingue trop peu incroyable
oui mais ce n'est pas l'avis d'alain
minc parce que il est économiste et
directeur financier du très grandes
entreprises
amag le scénario que nous venons de voir
pourrait-il se produire dans la réalité
le scénario vous avez bâti est à
l'évidence le scénario du pire est en
quelque sorte la pédagogique et la règle
de cette émission
cela dit il est possible si toute une
série de facteurs jouent dans le même
sens d'abord qu'un pays décident
d'utiliser cette bombe atomique
économique qui est le refus de payer ses
dettes et de le proclamer haut et fort
et qu'enfin jouer c'est là l'essentiel
une période de flottement de latence
pendant lequel les phénomènes
psychologiques peuvent se dérouler à
plein sans que les gouvernements
interviennent pour garantir calmer ou
sécurisé et dans une affaire de ce type
c'est une course de vitesse si elle
advient entre la rapidité d'intervention
des gouvernements et la rapidité de la
panique collective vous avait tablé sur
le fait que la panique collective
pourrait être plus rapide que les
gouvernements dans ce cas là quel est le
scénario le plus probable
votre scénario suppose que à la suite
des débats intellectuels qui ont pu
avoir sur le sujet aux états unis le
gouvernement américain hésite et ne
décide pas d'intervenir immédiatement
pour sauvegarder les banques et
sécuriser les dépose mon sentiment est
qu'en réalité le gouvernement américain
interviendrait tout de suite et donc
calmerait l'abcès cela dit je crois
qu'il faut pas se poser aujourd'hui le
problème dans ces termes-là le risque
d'une sorte d'explosion atomique
économique me paraît peu probable
en revanche ce que nous vivons à travers
la crise financière internationale
c'est une sorte de 1929 ralenti une
sorte de valse au tempo très très lent à
savoir que les banques qui aujourd'hui
sont très inquiètes pour leurs créances
font de moins en moins de près et ne
prête aux pays du tiers monde
que le minimum qui leur permet de re
payer leurs intérêts ceci étant destiné
à sauvegarder le bilan de ses propres
banques et de ce fait il en résultera
une diminution tendancielle lente
progressive du commerce mondial est
aussi une conséquence que l'on nommait
c'est que pendant la première période de
la crise de ce qu'on a appelé la crise
les pays en voie de développement
étaient ceux qui croient c'est le plus
et ont donc contribué à tirer nos pays
occidentaux
nous entrons dans une période où ces
pays-là croîtront beaucoup moins vite
que nous nous aurons donc même plus ce
moteur supplétifs sur lequel nous avons
tiré longtemps alors en effet c'est dans
une grande tempête que nous sommes
précipités nos bateau tangue
ils prennent l'eau ils menacent de
couler et savez vous ce qui me semble le
plus inquiétant dans une telle situation
c'est que si j'ai bien compris nos
gouvernements qu'ils soient de gauche ou
de droite julien de gauche de droite ne
savent plus comment piloter en pleine
tempête les commandes ne répond plus
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
une car acheter français pourquoi nous
avons besoin et deuxième par éviter le
l'immigration en france ils étaient
allongés l'âge de la retraite et
prolonger les études à ya beaucoup trop
d'étrangers il me semble que si on est
fiché dehors il y aurait beaucoup de
place pour le grand lorsque dans une
famille il n'y a pas beaucoup de points
en jeu on le doit d'abord à ses enfants
il redonne après aux voisins sinon face
à la situation et à sa gravité laisse
que sont la gravité des suppressions
d'emplois dans le pays
la position du parti communiste
internationaliste est claire nous
estimons que la majorité de députés ps
et pcf élu par la population de
laborieuses d'heurter d'urgence une loi
interdisant les licenciements
il suffit tout simplement de mettre de
l'ordre là où il ya le désordre on crée
des emplois et créer des emplois mais
sur la base de ce qui a été fait et sans
faire prendre un autre pays et à ses
habitants les risques excessifs il faut
une croissance nouvelles qui permettent
donc le marché à la consommation
intérieure je pense que face à la crise
il faut effectivement relancer la
production et la consommation
alors jeudi l'une des choses achetez
français
et oui chacun de nous a sa petite idée
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire et tout le
monde est convaincu d'avoir raison
il n'y a qu'à vous connaissez la formule
il n'y a qu'un hélas le bon sens et
souvent trompeurs si l'on se met à
prendre les gens au mot si l'on applique
réellement certaine sur mead bien on
s'aperçoit vite qu'ils sont pires que le
mal
pour vous le montrez nous avons choisi
trois remèdes miracles alors le tout
premier bien entendu les émigrés
puisqu'il ya deux millions de chômeurs
il n'y a expulsé deux millions d'émigrés
bon bon ça y est c'est fait ils sont
partis quelques mois après l'application
de cette décision
quelle est la situation de la france
autrement dit quelle place occupe est
réellement ces gens là chez nous pour
nous aider à répondre
on a imaginé un reportage fait par la
télévision algérienne sur la france sans
immigrés
la wolf renseigné il ya trois mois
les français avaient applaudi la
tragique décision de löw gouvernement
d'expulser tous les travailleurs
immigrés aujourd'hui des tonnes
d'ordures se lançait dans la plupart des
grandes villes des hordes de rats ont
refait leur apparition
l'armée a été réquisitionné mais elle
n'arrive pas à endiguer le fléau
face à cette situation les français
déchantent
c'est le foutoir mais il nous faut
quelques immigrés parce que les jeunes
français veulent rien faire
il est évident que c'est maintenant
qu'on s'aperçoit que les immigrés
avaient quand même une tâche qui était
intéressante pour la france je pense
qu'il a fallu garder ceux qui
travaillent pour eux pour faire le sale
boulot quoi au fait moutète il fallait
peut-être mais il ya plus grave encore
toute l'économie française a été
atteinte de plein fouet par la mesure
en trois mois la production automobile a
chuté de 40 % plus une usine fonctionne
à plein rendement
elle manque d'eau est ce les bâtiments
et travaux publics sont en faillite
en fait aucun secteur de l'économie
française n'est aujourd'hui épargné
on doit regarder cet homme il est
président directeur général des
fabriques de meubles de bureau une
partie de ces ouvriers étaient des
travailleurs immigrés il s'est élevé
contre leur expulsion
en vain le voilà bien avancés
son usine est actuellement arrêté nous
avions ici les immigrés qui était là
depuis dix ou vingt ans souvent même des
immigrés de la deuxième génération et en
conséquence il ya eu des problèmes à
résoudre tout à fait catastrophique au
niveau des familles il est tout à fait
évident que nous n'avons pas trouvé sur
le marché français bien qu'un nombre de
chômeurs très important le personnel
exactement qualifiés pour les remplacer
in war and baby derrière cette porte
depuis quinze jours
les patrons français siègent au comité
de crise face à la gravité de la
situation le cnpf a sommé le
gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités en accordant une
subvention spéciale aux entreprises les
plus durement touchés pour l'instant le
gouvernement a refusé
tessa d'économique la crise est
rapidement devenue politique il ya trois
mois les députés français n'avaient pas
été consultés sur l'expulsion des
immigrés les aujourd'hui presque tous
les partis politiques condamnent cette
décision non seulement l'expulsion des
étrangers pour deux ans au caractère
immoral de créer aucun emploi mais qui
plus est l on supprime penser que la
france pourrait vivre aujourd'hui sans
les immigrés qui ont apporté ce de ses
peines
et cette participation à son économie
c'était absurde
la démonstration vient maintenant être
faites après l'expulsion des
travailleurs immigrés capitaux étrangers
ont quitté le pays
le nombreuses banques ont fait faillite
protester contre cette mesure
une cinquantaine de pays d'afrique et
d'asie ont rompu leurs relations
diplomatiques et commerciales avec la
france gouvernement a suspendu ses
livraisons de matières premières de
pétrole de gaz
le français est désormais interdit dans
nos écoles c'en est fini du rayonnement
de la france dans le monde
la patrie des droits de l'homme s'est
déshonoré
aux soldes pour essayer
m
pour nous pour
les gains aux eaux
voilà ça c'était un ligne atta il y en a
bien d'autres
puisqu'il ya tant de chômeurs disent ont
parfois et puisque les services publics
marchent mal qu il n'y a qu'à engager
davantage de fonctionnaires lyon est-il
souhaitable de transformer les chômeurs
en fonctionnaires cénac 5000 habitants à
15 kilomètres d'angoulême a tenté il ya
un an une expérience originale au début
de 1983 quand l'entreprise michaud qui
emploie plus de 900 personnes doit
licencier une partie de son personnel
le maire de la ville décide d'embaucher
les salariés mis au chômage dans les
services publics hôpital mairie ptt
bureau d'aidé sociale
mais l'augmentation de charges fiscales
entraînés par ces embauches aura des
conséquences a prévu alors c'est un bon
travail que vous aviez chez michou va ça
faisait vingt ans j'ai travaillé
j avec 7 prises au sommet ce que ces
gens licenciés
chose que moi je pense à travers les
gouttes car qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
la décision du maire
c'est bien pour moi on a plus ou moins
tout le monde qui furieux autant
monsieur le maire il faudra quand même
trouver de l'argent pour financer toutes
ses créations de postes mais assure
qu'il faudra trouver de l'argent
marquez qui va payer tout le monde tout
le monde doit être solidaire
là dessus il faut être clair ouais nous
augmenterons les impôts locaux
que ce soit les impôts qui touche les
particuliers ou ceux qui touchent des
entreprises
aujourd'hui un an après l'expérience est
plus discuté certains doutent par
exemple de l'efficacité d'un
accroissement des effectifs de
l'administration
alors vous plaît au travail les trois
blocs
[Musique]
je suis agent d'administration d'euro
dette sociale bien je reçois les gens je
leur fais remplir leur demande pour
obtenir une aide
et puis je vérifier les dossiers
incomplets je transmets aux services
compétents et avant ça comment les gens
s'adressent directement aux services
compétents
mais il ya plus grave
ce que n'avait pas prévu le maire de
cénac c'est que l'augmentation des
impôts de l'avim indispensable créer des
emplois dans les services publics a dans
le même temps accru les difficultés de
l'entreprise locale le 15 janvier 1984
en effet hervé michaud patrons des
établissements michaud a annoncé un
nouveau train de licenciement
quand nous avons licencié l'année
dernière nous étions déjà très juste
nous avions vraiment beaucoup de mal
pour faire nos échéances vraiment oui
autrement on aurait pas licencier alors
aujourd'hui avec la concurrence
internationale
les charges qui vous tombe de tous les
côtés et non pas une augmentation de la
taxe professionnelle par dessus le
marché on n'y arrivait plus la taxe
professionnelle et celle que vous verser
à la ville oui c'est l'ancien patente
mais vous pouvez pas prendre vos
bénéfices par exemple pour la pour la
financer quel bénéfice
sommes en perte la seule chose que nous
pouvions faire c'est augmenter nos prix
et naturellement nous avons perdu
plusieurs marchés et alors alors il ya
moins de travail mais je n'ai pas les
moyens de payer les gens la grille 1
faire pourtant les nouveaux licenciés
on garde l espoir maintenant c'est vous
qui avez perdu votre travail
ouais cette fois c'est pour moi alors
que vous allez faire je sais joie on
attend la décision du maire il paraît
qu'il va être embauché
[Musique]
et si cette fable était une histoire
vraie ne parlons plus d'une petite ville
parlons de l'europe
depuis dix ans la part du revenu prélevé
par l'état sous forme d'impôts et de
cotisations sociales est monté à près de
50%
cet argent sert pour une grande part à
financer les salaires de la fonction
publique
mais cet argent a fait défaut aux
entreprises depuis dix ans
l'investissement industriel a cessé de
progresser
l'europe compte aujourd'hui 12 millions
de chômeurs il n'y a qu'à il n'y a qu'à
le petit jeu devient amusant
très vite le dernier exemple puisque les
produits étrangers nous envahissent et
ruine nos industries y'a qu'à fermer les
frontières
devant l'aggravation de la concurrence
internationale
le gouvernement français ait conduit à
prendre des mesures protectionnistes qui
reviennent à une quasi fermeture des
frontières
quelles sont les conséquences d'une
telle politique dans la vie quotidienne
des français pour le savoir nous avons
interrogé trois experts des échanges
internationaux
michel jobert ancien ministre du
commerce extérieur
monsieur jean boileau directeur du
groupe peugeot s à raymond les pincettes
contrebandiers écoutez j'ai d'abord
m'exclamer ouhlala ouhlala je souhaite
seulement que cette politique
se fasse pas ce scénario est dramatique
et nous avons quand intérêt à nous tenir
éloigné ça alors fermeture je joue le
jeu avec vous fermeture et bien nous
organisons quoi
la france transformée en albanie
mélancolique
c'est cela que l'on veut on en a un
exemple pas très loin de la france
nous verrons ce que très bien ce que
l'économie agricole coopérative dans un
pays qui est réduit à lui même il ne
faut pas oublier dans le domaine de
l'automobile que pour l'ensemble de
l'automobile française et pour peugeot
aussi une voiture sur deux est exportée
il ne faut pas négliger non plus dans le
cas de fermeture des frontières des
possibilités de mesures de rétorsion de
la part d'un certain nombre d'autres
pays je vous laisse à imaginer ce que
deviendrait l'automobile française si
elle perdait 50 % de son volume
même s'il est très faiblement compensées
par 5 ou 10 % de ventes supplémentaires
sur le marché national on travaille dans
l'import-export je crois oui les
contacts internationaux j'aime ça fait
marcher le commerce et mesures
restrictives adoptées par le
gouvernement d'evo permis de diversifier
nos activités
c'est ça avant j'étais surtout sur un
créneau financier je me transfère de
capitaux entre la france et suisse mais
aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui aux activités
c'est un beau grand nombre de secteurs
notamment l'électronique l'industrie
automobile industrie guise site les
textiles et signale blonde les échos les
jeux vidéo les appareils photos et tout
et plus précisément quels seront les
effets de cette décision sur les
acheteurs l'automobile vers is acheteurs
d'automobiles auront peut-être certaine
mesure un moindre choix
ensuite si les constructeurs
d'automobiles perdent ou perdent en
partie leurs possibilités d'exportation
ils auront de graves problèmes
d'organisation interne dans tous les
domaines ils auront des problèmes de
productivité en raison de la diminution
des volumes ils auront des problèmes
d'emploi et finalement c'est le
consommateur qui pourra en faire les
frais finaux par exemple dans
l'électronique
comment ça se passe eh ben on a créé le
réseau de distribution
c'est à dire
je vais vous donner un exemple bon on
achète des magnétoscopes dans les
supermarchés les grandes surfaces tout
près de la frontière
elle transmet à l'étranger on les paye
dont les 5 6 me de la bête et après on
les écoute facile en france dans les 20
mille âmes est alors résulte en eau dans
les frais de fonctionnement
le bureau les secrétaires des faunes
exemple up
alors oui les pots de vin oui on est bon
on fait deux fois les cubes le jeta fois
on prend souvent des mesures de
protection commerciale pour protéger
l'emploi
est ce que des mesures de fermeture
générale des frontières aurait un effet
positif sur l'emploi
on sait très bien quel sera l'effet
d'une fermeture générale les frontières
la france s'installera sur un palier de
production qui sera moins vite mais
j'aurais pas d'exportation nous
n'exportons plus il nous essaierons de
satisfaire aux besoins de de la
consommation intérieure sans avoir la
certitude d'y parvenir très vite
par conséquent dans un premier temps
l'emploi en prendre un sacré coup au
moral qu enfin profiter de la pénurie
moral et vous plaisantez blogueuse mais
dans les affaires la morale c'est
d'adapter l'offre à la demande
on vient d'avoir ensemble trois exemples
extrêmes dijon 3 caricature de il n'y a
qu'à le répugnant je vous dis bien
d'autres en réalité chacun de ces
remèdes miracles fait plus ou moins
partie de l'une ou l'autre des deux
grandes politiques économiques que les
gouvernements de l'europe ont pratiqué
depuis la guerre la politique de droite
ou celle de gauche disons pour
simplifier le frein de la droite ou
l'accélérateur de la gauche
aucune des politiques économiques
classiques ne fonctionnent plus calmes
avant c'est vrai ni l'accélérateur et le
frein et l'accélérateur le frein qu'est
ce que c'est l'accélérateur le frein le
frein d'abord c'est l'idée selon
laquelle il ne faut jamais que l'état
dépense plus que ce qu'ils gagnent et
dans cette optique
quand ça va mal eh bien il faut se
serrer la ceinture consommer moins
investir davantage accepté une
augmentation du chômage c'est un peu la
politique du père fouettard
si vous êtes sages si vous acceptez de
faire des sacrifices
ça ira mieux demain à la limite c'est
aussi un peu ce qu'on appelle le
monétarisme que madame thatcher applique
vous le savez en angleterre avec
beaucoup de fermeté et pourquoi ça ne
marche pas parce que ça augmente
considérablement le chômage qui coûte
cher à tout le monde et ce chômage
en plus il nuit à la modernisation des
entreprises parce que vous comprenez
bien que dans un pays quand il ya
beaucoup de chômage
un chef d'entreprise hésitent à mettre
un robot qui supprimerait encore
d'autres emplois pour que ça marche il
faut aussi que tout le monde soit
d'accord pour se serrer la ceinture
parce que sans cohésion sans un effort
de tous
rien n'est possible et enfin attention
si on fera une pro fort la voiture peut
quitter la route alors l'accélérateur
c'est le contraire et bien
l'accélérateur oui c'est le contraire
l'accélérateur c'est un peu ce qu'on a
appelé le keynésianisme
vous savez la pensée de keynes en
économie ça a été une révolution inouïe
c'est celui qui a dit mme pour relancer
l'économie c'est pas compliqué c'est pas
compliqué il suffit de libérer les
désirs de consommer davantage de
dépenser plus que ce qu'on gagne
et tant pis s'il ya un déficit
budgétaire en achetant plus les
consommateurs feront tourner les usines
et au bout du compte on retombera sur
nos pieds
seulement ça aussi ça ne fonctionne plus
pourquoi parce que il n'y a plus de
croissance
aujourd'hui dans nos pays et puis pour
des tas d'autres raisons plus technique
je vais simplement vous en citer deux
faciles à comprendre celle là la
première c'est que parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui des pays développés nos
économies sont de plus en plus
interdépendantes les unes les autres
dans ce que nous consommons dans ce que
nous achetons dans les matières
premières qui font tourner nos usines
une bonne partie vient de l'étranger et
par conséquent si dans un pays comme la
france vous distribuer davantage de
pouvoir d'achat
cet argent risque de servir à relancer
les industries des pays voisins et la
deuxième raison c'est quoi là-bas c'est
ça justement c'est celle des piscines
extérieures
quand un pays franchit la ligne rouge de
déficit extérieur il cesse d'être libre
de sa politique économique pour la bonne
raison qu'il doit emprunter à l'étranger
pour faire ses fans mois or vous
comprenez bien qu'un pays qui
s'endettent affaiblit sa monnaie est la
limite même ils risqueraient de perdre
son indépendance nationale
l'accélérateur donc c'était les
politiques de gauche et le frein les
politiques économiques de droite
oui enfin disons oui disons dans une
certaine mesure le frein c'est la droite
l'accélérateur
c'est la gauche mais c'est pas si simple
que ça il est fréquent par exemple que
des politiques de droite commence par le
frein et finissent par l'accélérateur
pourquoi sabah notamment pour des
raisons qui peuvent être électorale
regardent étonnés par exemple ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui aux états unis
monsieur reagan l'espace c'est l'homme
de droite type dans sa réputation
internationale et quelle politique fait
tilt et bien c'est aussi celui qui fait
le plus la politique de l'accélérateur
la politique du déficit
gfr et puis l inverse on voit des
politiques de gauche qui pour éviter des
difficultés financières sont bien obligé
d'appuyer sur le frein
s'il y avait aujourd'hui un modèle de
politique économique parmi les pays qui
nous entourent ça ce serait la crise
date de maintenant plus de dix ans voyez
vous un pays voisin qui est vraiment
sorti de la crise
ce modèle ça ne sûrement pas
l'angleterre avec ses trois millions de
chômeurs ça n'est même pas l'allemagne
qui a pourtant l'économie la plus
puissante et la société la mieux
organisée avec son grand asus pour
sortir de la crise chacun de ces pays
comme le nôtre d'ailleurs donne la
preuve qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
solution tout seul il n'y a plus de
solution solitaire
s'ils agissent isolément en ordre
dispersé les gouvernements des pays
européens ne peuvent plus aujourd'hui
que gérer la crise oui oui si j'ai bien
compris michel albert les recettes
politique ne marche plus aucune les
issues paraissent boucher nous sommes
bel et bien condamné à ne plus nous
enrichir et peut-être bientôt à nous
appauvrir et ed rappelez vous il ya
quelques années
tout le monde parlait de la croissance
zéro à ce moment là beaucoup de gens
pensaient que ce serait une bonne chose
on rêvait d'une société douce plus
tranquille de lens 0-1 et cetera
c'était une utopie hérité de mai 68 ou
souvenez et bien en 1984 nous y sommes
dans la croissance zéro le problème
c'est qu'on s'aperçoit maintenant
qu'elle est moins rose comme le croyait
et on n'a pas tout vu
imaginez seulement qu'après les trente
glorieuses après 30 ans de forte
croissance nous ayons 30 ans de
croissance zéro
imaginons commentant verrait la
situation dans 30 ans
dire en 2014 depuis cinq ans six ans je
me passionne pour la crise a créé crise
qui a débuté dans les années 80 elle a
débuté mollement lentement et on
n'envisage pas à ce moment là que
l'effondrement du système économique
puisse provoquer un effondrement du
système démocratique de cette démocratie
à laquelle depuis très longtemps nous
étions habitués à kout mais la
démocratie le liait à la progression
économique
oui la démocratie liée à la progression
économique et cette formule mettait à
mal les thèses des partisans de la
croissance zéro au début malgré les
grèves à laver les fermetures
d'entreprises
oh ça me fait toujours mal y pense et
que ce n'était qu'un mauvais moment à
passer
mais la faillite même en allemagne alors
que l'allemagne était le pays qui avait
le mieux supporter la crise où le moins
mal la faillite même en allemagne des
différents systèmes de protection
sociale allait être durement ressenti
c'est la réalité de l'état providence
qui s'effondre plus d'allocations
familiales son score diminuer payet
travailler plus de médecine gratuite ou
presque gratuite plus de retraite
garanti en 1990 il a fallu vivre
nous avons dû vivre comme vive et nos
arrière grands parents
c'est à dire sans filet et c'est la
rupture de tout un tissu d'habitude une
rupture d'autant plus cruel que l'état
augmentent sans arrêt les impôts et que
naturellement cela la met
or pas la situation sociale que le
chômage augmente que dans les grandes
villes
insécurité se préciser qu'à ce moment-là
secret à un peu partout les milices
privées et on assiste à un véritable
retour en arrière de sang en 300 ans je
ne sais pas certains parleront d'un
retour au web
chaque classe sociale chaque catégorie
est saisie d'une fièvre de
revendications mais lorsqu'il n'y a plus
de croissance on se bat pas contre
l'état impuissant incapable
on se bat à ce moment là contre le
voisin le voisin qui devient l'ennemi
car le voisin vous prendre votre travail
votre emploi votre salaire
tout ce qui fait l'ordinaire des preuves
et c'est à partir de 1990 que se
multiplient les manifestations les
défilés les maîtres et répressions
naturellement et que s'amorcent ce cycle
infernal au bout duquel fatalement la
démocratie se trouvera mise à mal en
1990 un journaliste français
un vent de cette formule à croissance
molle société dure
en vérité je pense qu'il faudrait dire à
croissance nulle société dure
alors commence pour la france et pour
les français
les véritables année croire
volontairement nous avons renoncé en
dire plus relancée à savoir ce que
pourrait être l'issue de ces futures
années noires qu'évoquait henri amouroux
la dernière fois qu'on a parlé d'années
noires chez nous c'était avant la guerre
et on sait sur quoi elles ont débouché
ces années noires la la dernière guerre
celle de 1939 était le point
d'aboutissement de la catastrophe
économique des années 30 dans l'histoire
voyez vous c'est souvent comme cela les
guerres sont les dernières des solutions
qu'imagine du gouvernement pour sortir
de situation sans issue
mais alors est ce qu'il faut craindre
pour de bon une nouvelle guerre mondiale
[Musique]
quand les sociétés s'engourdissent quand
les égoïsmes l'emportent sur le
sentiment de l'intérêt général
quand les usines tournent au ralenti
quand le chômage devient insupportable
quand toutes les issues semblent bloquer
la guerre la guerre réveille les
sociétés somnolente la guerre développe
l'esprit de sacrifice
la guerre fait reculer le chômage
la guerre permet la rénovation rapide du
parc immobilier
la guerre relance l'activité économique
la guerre accélère le progrès
scientifique
la gueule
le coup de fouet j'ai vu manquer
alain minc la deuxième guerre mondiale
nous at elle permis de sortir de la
crise de 1929
toutes les politiques économiques telles
que celles que nous menons keynésienne
semble savoir monétariste sans le savoir
de rétablissement des comptes des
entreprises ont été menées entre 1933 et
or en 1938 la situation dans certains
pays étaient plus mauvaise qu'elle ne
l'était quand qu'elle ne l'était en 33
en 1940 le chômage aux états unis était
plus fort qu'au moment de la première
élection de roosevelt
donc ce n'est pas en réalité la théorie
économique où la pratique économique qui
nous ont sorti la crise de 29
c'est en effet alors il ya quelques
provocations à le dire compte tenu de
tout ce qui s'attache à la guerre c'est
en effet l'effet de la guerre pourquoi
l'effet de la guerre parce qu'il a été
doux c'est une baisse drastique du
pouvoir d'achat et donc la recréation de
très grands besoins de consommation et
d'un très grand appétit à la fois
matérielle et psychologique de consommer
et c'est enfin dans certains pays une
table rase total de l'appareil de
production qui a été reconstruit à
partir de zéro et la reconstruction
depuis rien pour le japon et pour
l'allemagne est probablement un des
facteurs essentiels de la croissance
plus rapide qui sont connus après 1945
la guerre c'est bien mais la guerre
atomique
c'est mieux alors n'hésitez plus laissez
vous tenter
partez pour l' aventure
[Musique]
je
et
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la guerre pourrait
de nouveau servir d'issue à la crise
économique
votre formulation ressemble un problème
de mathématiques la crise donc la guerre
ou la crise égale la guerre cela a été
relativement vrai et d'une certaine
façon ce fut le cas pour la guerre 39 et
précédemment
sans tomber dans un marxisme primaire il
est clair qu'entre les crises
économiques et les conflits il ya une
relation même s'ils n'étaient pas
nécessairement de cause à effet alors
est ce que cette relation imprécise est
encore vrai en temps de guerre nucléaire
j'ai tendance à penser que la question
ne peut même pas se poser la guerre dans
sa fonction économique indépendamment de
son cortège d'horreurs c'était une
disparition partielle appareil de
production et la capacité de repartir à
zéro et une certaine façon de rebondir
ceci suppose et que la destruction reste
proportionnelle
elle n'affecte pas l'intégralité de la
guerre de 39-45 a représenté pour des
pays comme la france les disparitions de
25 30% mais il restait 65 ou 70%
or la guerre atomique que pour autant
qu'elle puisse un jour à venir
et l'inversé même de cela
vous voyez tout cela n'est pas très gai
impossible
europe de revenir en arrière c'est à
dire la croissance forte aux années
glorieuses mais elle ne peut pas non
plus continuer comme aujourd'hui dans la
croissance zéro pour finir on a vu que
même la violence comme la guerre est
inimaginable
sous peine d'apocalypse nucléaire alors
alors c'est une bien étrange situation
que nous vivons
toutes les portes sont apparemment fermé
6 et d'une crise qu'il s'agit alors en
effet peut-être que nous n'en sortirons
pas mais est ce bien une crise ou
s'agit-il d'autres choses
[Musique]
là
c'était aussi une crise terrible l'aimé
sorti la renaissance la fin de l'ancien
régime c'était un effondrement pouvons
tabler sanglant qu' il n' est sorti la
démocratie la révolution industrielle
s'était aussi une tragédie pour des
millions de gens là les sorties au bout
du compte notre prospérité et demain
qu'est ce qui va se passer le mot crise
ça veut dire deux choses c'est lui dire
à la fois une épreuve une menace bien
sûr mais ça veut dire aussi une chance
et un progrès et dans toute crise il ya
les deux aspects ya celui qu'on voit
c'est un peu comme un accouchement si
vous voulez une crise il ya ce convoyage
kessa alliès qui fait mal
il ya ce qui fait peur aussi et puis il
ya comme une naissance des naissances
souvent invisible si je comprends bien
c'est une forme de l'accouchement à
l'heure actuelle oui un bon et sur quoi
on va pouvoir déboucher je crois que les
gens disent on sans démagogie imbéciles
pas ce serait trop facile mais les gens
en condition modeste
il semble très bien que c'est très
difficile sommes très bien quelque chose
qui ne va pas il semble très bien que
c'est pas les idéologies quelle qu'elle
soit ils peuvent résoudre les problèmes
on sait très bien que c'est de la blague
aujourd'hui dieu merci ils commencent à
comprendre ça alors comment on peut
vraiment s'en sortir
hélas combien de temps bon pas goûté à
l'or dans combien de temps sait pas ce
qu'on va traiter ce soir je crois pas
trop vite se dire sérieusement dans
combien de temps va s'en sortir
gym hâtivement en revanche mais non ça
dépend de nous
ça dépend pas des technocrates ni des
gouvernants pour l'essentiel cela tombe
bien mais bon c'est sûr les gens qui
nous regardent qui vous poseraient que
je pense que j'ai reposé il faut que je
leur dise que ça dépend de tout le monde
avec ça dépend d'abord de la confiance
que nous avons dans nos problèmes mais
la crise nos difficultés de toute nature
c'est pas quelque chose comme ça qui
tombe du ciel c'est pas un déterminisme
historique la crise
c'est notre production c'est nous qui
l'avons fait par notre inconscience par
nos défauts d'organisation
tenez par les retards par exemple avec
lesquels on a engagé des
restructurations industrielles dont tout
le monde savait bien qu'il fallait les
faire et à l'heure
adéquat à côté de ça il y à des
phénomènes nouveaux des phénomènes de
germination d'adaptation de toute nature
un exemple à propos du chômage a le pour
moi ce qui est l'aspect dominant de la
crise c'est le chômage
bon je précise que je suis pas
spécialement optimiste dans ce domaine
que la plupart des pays européens vont
continuer à avoir de l'augmentation du
chômage pendant encore bien des années 1
mais néanmoins il ya des adaptations qui
se font et on n'en parle pas
suffisamment de ces adaptations
il ya par exemple le fait que de plus en
plus les travailleurs acquiert la
possibilité de choisir leur durée de
travail
c'est vrai ça eh bien écoutez c'est
tellement vrai que d'après les derniers
rapports officiels depuis une dizaine
d'années la moitié des emplois nouveaux
qui ont été créés en europe et sont pas
très nombreux mais je te dire en face à
se porte quand même sur des millions ce
n'est ce pas la moitié des emplois
nouveaux sont des emplois à temps réduit
pas tous pas tous par libre choix mais
la grande majorité par libre choix
encore une entreprise en difficulté
cette fois c'est une fabrique de pain
biologique de produits naturels de la
région parisienne qui est touché près de
la moitié de ses 120 salariés risquent
d'être licenciés oui nous sommes en
grève illimitée pour le moment on attend
la direction la décision surtout
et bien pour éviter 45 emplois
le licenciement mon intérêt à mon
entendement l'intérêt c'est que les
ouvriers de cette entreprise travaille
que l'entreprise gagne de l'argent et
qu'elles se situent plus vite possible
sur le marché c'est ça mon intérêt et je
le crois beaucoup plus dans une solution
originale que dans une solution à mesure
un peu désespéré comme comme
licenciement collectif cinquième jour de
grève
quels seront les noms des 45 sacrifier
le comité d'entreprise débats depuis le
matin de la proposition de la direction
plutôt que de licencier près de la
moitié du personnel pourquoi ne pas
conserver l'ensemble des salariés à
mi-temps
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous avez des stadiers
se faire en plein accord avec le
personnel et les membres du comité nous
avons opté pour la solution de travail à
mi temps
je pense que dans l'état actuel des
choses c'est pour nous l'avions souhaité
qu'une solution sage la meilleure
certaines personnes entrent match aurait
un bruit mais c'est un partage
cette s'améliore blanchir aura le
personnel tricard et surpasser sur
quelle base salariale vous avez
dans des g20 les chiffres à cette façon
sur la base c'est 50 % c'est-à-dire la
prime ça mène à 75% de environ 10 et 15
mars plus de 600 personnes seront
employées elles vont complet et pour les
petits salaires et les salaires au
dessus ou en garde on regardera le
personnel et font à mi temps je pense
qu'on obtient le maximum de garanties et
la nouvelle organisation fava être mise
en place dans l'est dans les 15 jours et
je pense que c'est une solution où tout
le monde se sentira vraiment concerné et
c'est ce semble plus concernées il y
aura peut-être davantage le productible
je pense je l'espère vous à les
redistribuer
quand les moyens nous permettrons oui
c'est à dire qu'il faut d'abord assainir
l'état financier de la société
mais vous avez éviter une grève vous
vous donniez déjà terminée oui bien
entendu
oui mais la grève c'est la mort de
l'entreprise romande il fallait
l'arrêter sinon sinon il y avait une
troisième voie qui était que tout le
monde disparaissent
l'entreprise aussi et je pense que le
comité l'a très bien compris
[Musique]
trois mois après le travail à mi temps
est devenu une nouvelle habitude
comment organise-t-il leur temps libre
c'est mieux qu'avant parce que ça nous
permet d'avoir davantage de temps point
de vue loisirs et se détendre un petit
peu que de respirer ce toujours enfermés
on apprécie financièrement comment vous
en sortez la financièrement bien entendu
sa veste couleur d'achat et c'est une
question d'organisation à la base mais
un cadre aux mains mi-temps ça paraît
pas très grosse vague vous restez
vraiment un mi temps
non vous avez un peu raison si vous
voulez dans la mesure où les journées
sont longues pour un cadre qui travaille
dans une pmi et je déborde un peu sur ce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler le vrai mi
temps michel au prix vous êtes président
directeur général d'une moyenne
entreprise tous seront bien utiles mais
c'est du cinéma c'est de la fiction
pourquoi vous avez accepté de nous voir
arriver c'est un homme que c'est assez
difficile en intéressant parce que je
crois que la proposition de solutions
est une solution est une proposition à
la fois être peu courante et qui
seraient de nature à aider à résoudre
des problèmes difficiles que traverse
momentanément une entreprise je crois
que s'il est si cette fiction avec des
réalités et que le comité d'entreprise
est vraiment choisi
la solution dont nous avons parlé je
crois que les énergies le taux de
créativité l'enthousiasmé avec lequel
les gens se réveillent au travail aurait
permis sans doute de les montrer quelque
chose d'intéressant
oui bon mais ça c'est imaginaire cet
imaginaire mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que même aujourd'hui en france
dans la crise il ya des tas de progrès
nouveaux d'innovation qui permettent à
des gens de mener une vie bien meilleur
qu'avant
il ya même des créations d'emplois
nouvelles auxquelles on pense jamais
qu'ils sont ce qu'on appelle des emplois
du troisième secteur des emplois de type
associatif culturel et tout ça et j'en
moi j'en connais un certain nombre je
connais par exemple tenait un de mes
anciens camarades leena un énarque et un
énarque de mon pays d'un vieux pays vous
sauvez traditionnel qui est l'avant dès
qu'on ressent on croit que c'est un pays
même un peu attardé à ce type il a fait
des choses fantastiques
il a fait des choses fantastiques parce
que il est à la fois l'homme de
l'association l'homme de la tradition et
l'homme de l'ordinateur il est tout ça à
la fois
j'étais élève à l'ena
je suis parti parce que je m'y ennuyais
c'est en 1978 je suis revenu ensuite
pour devenir sous préfet pour repartir
parce que j'avais un rêve d'enfant que
je voulais accomplir
[Musique]
et serait gelé accompli et dure depuis
six ans et ce rêve il consistait
finalement à marier la tradition orale
et l'ordinateur c'est à dire à mettre en
valeur une histoire un pays un
patrimoine avec les technologies les
plus modernes
le puy du fou c'est aujourd'hui bien sûr
la quadriphonie le laser l'électronique
stroboscopes l'informatique
mais c'est surtout 30000 habitants
originaires de 13 communes 15 cents
membres actifs dans l'association dont
650 acteurs qui jouent sur une scène de
13 hectares et qui accueille chaque été
deux cent cinquante mille spectateurs
avec un budget le budget de
l'association du puy du fou qui est de 1
milliard de centimes
[Musique]
le spectacle a suscité une multitude
d'activités où chacun a éveillé épanouie
une nouvelle passion par exemple piero
qui est peintre en bâtiment est devenu
directeur des accessoires demandé de
faire des lanternes
comme on n'a pas d'argent il fallait se
débrouiller nous mêmes on a trouvé des
vieux bidons là et puis en faisant des
gabarits on a réussi à faire une
lanterne les bénéfices parce que ce
spectacle fait des bénéfices et bien ses
bénéfices là bas on l'est on les
réinvestit pour recréer encore autre
chose dans d'autres domaines c'est notre
c'est notre ça comme ça pour le plaisir
jean marie qui dans la vie et plâtriers
président en même temps ou destinées de
l'association
à moi ça vous le verset complètement ma
vie avant si vous voulez le domaine de
la culture de l'art de la communication
je croyais et cela uniquement réservée à
une élite
chaque année on va jusqu à subventionner
les pouvoirs publics jeudi mer jusqu'à
subventionner les points publique et
chaque automne on crée une nouvelle
activité une nouvelle aventure
on appelle ça quand on vote notre budget
la part du rêve
la part du rêve en 1981 ça a été pour
nous une autre manière de communiquer
consistant à relier l'information au
pays avec l'information sur le monde
entier et finalement à m beyrouth a
porté de bocage et le tiers-monde la
porte et de générosité
les titres de ce journal oslo villes
polonaises avec la remise du prix nobel
de la paix aujourd'hui cette radio émet
24 heures sur 24
emploie 46 permanent avec en plus 150
bénévoles qui nous aident chaque jour et
touche 600 mille auditeurs grâce à cinq
studios décentralisée en couvrant cinq
départements
notre radio est considéré comme la
première radio régionale de france
cette aventure communautaire a scellé
des destins tout à fait inattendue par
exemple jacky sabiron qui présente
chaque jeudi soir l'émission de musique
classique a commencé sa vie
professionnelle comme boulanger
personnellement je préfère
l'interprétation dirigé par coline davis
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'ampleur
colline davis joue beaucoup avec les
cordes nos différentes expériences nous
persuade que le loisir la culture la
communication secteur d'avenir
rejaillissent dès maintenant sur toute
l'économie de la région
la différence des marges par rapport aux
grandes structures traditionnelles
c'est sa souplesse sa rapidité les
grandes structures traditionnelles sont
inaptes à haut risque à la création
parce qu'au fond ce sont des aventures
qui ont réussi mais qu'on a figé dans un
droit écrit alors que nous ce qu'on fait
c'est de l'ordre de la coutume ça bouge
ça avance sur les jours
[Musique]
la crise s'est pas seulement une
révolution économique c'est peut-être
avant tout une révolution culturelle en
ce sens que si on veut aujourd'hui on
peut créer communiquer n'importe où les
nouvelles technologies que ce soit la
radio la vidéo la micro informatique
sont à notre disposition et elles sont
par définition légère souple
décentralisée et accessible
financièrement
ce que nous avons fait n'importe qui
peut le faire en france aujourd'hui
n'importe où et tous ceux qui
comprennent cette nouvelle situation
près nous prendrons une longueur
d'avancé sur la crise un grand spectacle
l'anem de madère une radio est la
prochaine étape
j'ai très envie de faire une télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
goody michel albert tout ça c'est bien
gentil j'ai très bien ma face à un petit
côté quand même folklorique bravo mais
la grande industrie c'est ça qui
m'intéresse qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors vous voulez qu'on vous montre
l'usiné auparavant auparavant je
voudrais vous dire il ya longtemps que
vous n'êtes pas allé en californie yves
montand ou oui à peu près deux ans
notamment parce que je peux vous dire
que là bas la californie c'est redevenu
une extraordinaire terre de création et
de création d'emplois et bien des gens
comme philippe de villiers
quelques dizaines d'entre eux ont créé
là bas tu es milliers d'emplois c'est
pas folklorique ne croyait pas que ça
soit folklorique aujourd'hui de créer
les radios libres de créer des
universités populaires de créer un temps
dû être logés s'agissait pour paula pour
la question du spectacle qui vous dire
je suis pour le spectacle bien entendu
de l'électronique du spectacle il faut
le faire contre l'entente des choses
merveilleuses bon mais je me disais très
bien mais non mais ça alors là vous avez
raison c'est vrai qu'il faut surtout pas
faire diversion il s'agit pas de dire
aux jambes a en effet voilà avec le
folklore on s'en sort pas du tout vous
voulez qu'on vous montre une voie là eh
bien on va vous montrer une usine est
une usine dans le bocage vendéen au bord
du bocage vendéen tout près du puy du
fou dans ce pays dont tout le monde
croit qu'il est encore arriérés attarder
un pays paysan vous allez vraiment
longtemps une usine de sortie de crise
75 ans la famille fabriquer des bateaux
de pêche à mort son métier était celui
de constructeur de bateaux or pour ce
métier là c'était le début de la fin la
meilleure preuve c'est depuis il ya plus
de constructeurs de bateaux en france
alors la question se pose est est-ce
qu'il fallait s'épuiser sur un secteur
qui était qui était mort ou est-ce qu'il
fallait partir dans un nouveau secteur
là où nous avons eu de la chance c'est
que toujours dans le domaine du bateau
si le bateau de pêche classique en bois
était mort il y avait la plaisance qui
commençaient juste dans la réaction de
la troisième génération c'était de dire
ne nous épuisons pas sur ce qui est fini
mais par contre puisque il ya ce créneau
qui perd dans lequel on voyait a quand
même un très grand avenir
alors la longue vie à fond ce premier
choix fondamental passé de la
construction en bois au polyester 1 et
roux a dû le faire à l'âge de 21 ans
lorsqu'elle a repris la marche des
chantiers bénéteau de 1964 à ce jour
l'entreprise familiale est passé de 17
salariés à plus de 1000 et son chiffre
d'affaires de 3 millions à 300 millions
en francs constants pour fabriquer un
bateau de six mètres
il ya deux ans il fallait 250 heures de
travail ils n'en font plus que 150
aujourd'hui senteurs de gagner et en
plus au lieu de licencier des chantiers
bénéteau embauches bien sûr parce que si
on n'avait pas gagné c'est sans peur
aujourd'hui il est probable qu'on serait
pas là où qu'on soit en difficulté
tandis qu en ayant gagné ses senteurs on
a élargi notre clientèle on a élargi nos
marchés vous adonner au japon bien sûr
nous sommes allés au japon au printemps
et ce qui m'intéresse au japon c'était
voir justement où en était la
concurrence
est ce que ces usines étaient pas plus
moderne que les nôtres est-ce que son
personnel n'était pas plus productif que
les nôtres et on est allé partout où on
trouve des gens dans notre secteur
regardez l'ours leur investissement leur
établissement comme ils sont plus
modernes
justement ce petit tour ça nous a
énormément rassuré parce que on n'a pas
trouvé l'outil plus moderne que les
nôtres on n'a pas forcément trouvé une
manne
beaucoup plus actif que la nôtre donc
quand on est conscient quand on a vu
quand on a pesé le pour le compte et
qu'on a surtout pesé sa concurrence on
est beaucoup plus tranquille ce qu'il
faut en permanence et se remettre en
cause en permanence mais c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est tranquille qu'il
faudra pas regarder d'un six mois parce
que les choses évoluent très vite
et peut-être que dans six mois il y en
aura qui aura grossi beaucoup plus vite
des choix qui deviennent des réussites
des gains de productivité
impressionnants les ouvertures vers
l'extérieur spectaculaire année trou
c'est une samouraï vendéenne un de ces
entrepreneurs du troisième type qui
fonce face au vent très bien mais je
continue à être l'avocat du diable
dites moi combien en france de bénéteau
oui en effet on parle jamais des
bénéteau je suis sûr que la plupart des
téléspectateurs n'ont jamais entendu
parler d'une entreprise aussi exemplaire
que celle là c'est toujours la même
raison les bonnes nouvelles sont pas des
nouvelles on part on parle toujours dans
la tempête de la crise des grands arbres
qui tombent en catastrophe dans la forêt
mais on parle pas des petites pousses
qui font des progrès printemps après
printemps eh bien écoutez en gros ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que à peu près un
tiers de l'industrie française est
aujourd'hui je dirais pas seulement
compétitive mais hyper compétitif
j'entends par là que ce sont les
entreprises qui augmentent et qui
augmente rapidement les exportations et
vous savez y en a dans la plupart des
secteurs et je m'entends bien moi je
vais vous dire la première qui me vient
à l'esprit vous savez pas laquelle celle
c'est l'entreprise yves montand est ce
qu'on vous avait expliqué que vous
fabriquez des emplois vous saviez pas et
vous pourriez m'expliquer comment vous
faites pour évoquer des emplois quand on
part en tout un tel temps part en
tournée je sais que j'ai amené près de
40 personnes nous étions 40 avec des
musiciens des machines ou les électro le
camionneur les camions et tout c'est
déjà pas si mal
donc vous êtes donc un bonnet tout bien
c'est vrai quand on me demande comment
je gagnerai me dire aussi combien je
rapporte à l'état
mais c'est fini c'est pas faux mais
c'est pas grave parce que dix emplois
vous en créer directement quand vous
partez avec toute votre équipe en
amérique gérant pour gagner des dollars
d'accord mais attention ces dollars en
rentrant en france voulait verser à
votre banque et ça signifie ça que le
déficit extérieur de la france en dollar
diminue
or voyez-vous il montant ce qui fait la
limite à la croissance ce qui fait
l'augmentation du chômage c'est
simplement le déficit extérieur c'est ça
la ligne rouge que nous n'avons jamais
le droit de franchir
c'est évident qu'en france aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya davantage de
talent mots que devenait tôt si vous
permettez à la wii ça ça c'est sûr
qu'elle va faire pour justement
précisément pour cette question de 2,2
albeau par rapport à beaulieu pour ça il
faut penser d'européens il faut penser
l'europe et un malheur on ose à peine le
dire n'est ce pas parce que les gens de
notre génération
ils en ont tellement ras-le-bol d'une
europe embêtante d'une europe ennuyeuse
d'une europe qui je ne sais même pas
comment l'exprimer n'est ce pas est un
flot de paperasse et et de misérables
chamaillage entre les différents pays
mais pour vous montrer que ça pourrait
être autre chose
il se trouve que j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec une équipe de jeunes et j'ai
été frappé de voir ce que leur
imagination à eux nous permet de montrer
dans ce domaine nous perdons montré que
non seulement ce n'est pas ennuyeux les
affaires de l'europe si elle est faite
si on l'a fait alors regardez
première visite officielle de la
nouvelle présidente de l'europe en gaz
est chère aux états unis reçu par le
président reagan madame thatcher s'est
félicité de la bonne coopération entre
les états unis d'amérique et les états
unis d'europe
le président américain lui souhaite que
l'europe cesse de pratiquer des taux
d'intérêt trop élevés les qu'une autre
monnaie nationale vient en effet de
crevé tous les plafonds à la bourse de
wall street en côte en cette semaine de
dollars 50,2 la banque centrale
américaine a été obligée d'intervenir
une nouvelle fois pour soutenir le cours
du dollar à aix-la-chapelle capitale de
l'europe la conférence américano
soviétique sur le désarmement nucléaire
en europe pourrait aboutir rapidement
c'est ce que vient d'affirmer le
représentant des états-unis d'europe qui
préside cette rencontre les deux
puissances semblent en effet sur le
point d'accepter une importante
réduction de leur armement nucléaire
stationner sur notre continent comme le
souhaite une écrasante majorité
d'européens
[Musique]
la 10e foire européenne d'informatique
vient d'ouvrir ses portes à paris en
vedette le micro-ordinateur b-hop quatre
mises au point par le géant européen de
l'informatique diop diop regroupe le
savez les anciennes sociétés cll icl
olivetti et philips l'iap occupent des
jarres 30 % du marché mondial de
l'informatique et espère avec ce nouveau
modèle emporté les trois quarts du
marché de la micro-informatique sur sa
lancée biop pourrait racheter
prochainement une partie des actions de
la firme américaine ibm
[Musique]
plus de frontières pour le langage
grâce aux efforts conjugués des firmes
comme sonnés grundig la tra du sed
s'améliore indispensable maintenant à
tous les européens la tra du set va
peser moins de 300 grammes pour les
hommes elle pourra s'accrocher à la
ceinture et pour les dames prendre place
dans leur sac à main
muni d'un micro ultra sensibles il ne
sera plus nécessaire de la déplacer pour
capter les voix de vos interlocuteurs
la traduction se fera instantanément
dans la langue de votre choix
ce nouveau modèle de train du 7 doit
être commercialisé dans toute l'europe
dès le mois prochain
cinecitta recentre mondiale du cinéma
dans les studios romains le réalisateur
sergio leone et vient de donner cette
semaine le premier coup de manivelle sa
gigantesque fresque historique
il était une fois l'europe une fresque
qui l'a préparé pendant dix ans pour ce
film sergio leone est dispose d'un
budget record de 40 milliards dès qu le
tournage qui va durer trois mois
s'effectuera dans le plus grand secret
on sait simplement que sergio leone et a
choisi pour l'assister deux réalisateurs
américains george lucas et francis ford
coppola qui viennent d'émigrer pour
s'installer définitivement à cinecitta
[Musique]
le 4e congrès du syndicat européen des
viticulteurs a rejeté la proposition du
gouvernement de créer un fonds d aide
aux agriculteurs du tiers-monde
les viticulteurs ne reçoivent aucune
subvention du gouvernement et leur
syndicat estime qu'il n'a pas à financer
un tel fonds dead
les viticulteurs sont l'une des
catégories professionnelles les plus
riches d'europe depuis le succès mondial
de vie nicolas la boisson qui est
maintenant la plus consommée dans le
monde et qui est un savant coupage de
tous les vins européens un coupage dont
la recette est jalousement gardée
secrète
le ministre de l'agriculture européenne
andreas papandreou a qualifié la
décision du syndicat d'égoïste il est du
devoir des agriculteurs européens de
venir en aide aux pays les plus pauvres
at il déclaré
[Musique]
et vous je ne sais si nous vous avons
convaincu mais moi je retire une idée de
tout ça c'est que finalement tout ce
qu'on peut dire tout ce qu'on peut faire
en définitive c'est vous et vous seuls
qui trouverait la solution n'y a pas de
sauveur suprême
il n'y a pas de super kf ya pas de
superman c'est vous rendez vous par la
main sachez ce que vous voulez demander
le voyant ce qu'on peut faire et avancer
alors où on aura la crise où on sortira
de la crise et dans les deux cas leur à
ce qu'on mérite
voilà excusez moi j'arrive à la fin
bonsoir et à bientôt
[Musique]